[Music]
in speak up news yeah
submitted by say boots cats say boots
cats boots cats no you don't tell me
what to do what's boots cats boots cats
boots cats VBox USA Gymnastics has
stated it will not find mckayla maroney
for breaking her NDA in regards to her
abuse scandal with the USA tell me no i
only hear about the USA Gymnastics if
there's a scandal right [ __ ] what
else do you hear about it remember Andy
it doesn't apply if it if it's illegal
yeah
NDA means non-disclosure agreement
yeah well this has been a great video
we'll see you guys next time
we'll be going over taxes the
molestation okay I read about that way
our US team is getting molested yes yep
why these kids a lower years yeah
they've been hiding it and not one
person ok people the sweet kids alone
I'm glad on I want to kill so many ptoo
why are adults so gross like why are
there so many gross adults I mean I do
it willingly but there's things called
laws that will punish me you shooting
something no don't say that
it's not fair no for killing no the only
way I want to touch kids is his way yeah
hands where we can see them his tongue
is in his mouth all that is upside down
yeah right hey I'm a touch audio kids so
be careful
no you know you're afraid yeah so this
whole thing is surrounding Larry Nasser
who joined the USA Gymnastics as an
athletic trainer back in 1986 Oh God
sounds okay so far sounds okay so far
pretty no no
so geo don't react yeah it's okay yeah
got a job at McDonald's all right so his
sexual abusing you see you see I didn't
drop the gun look look I misjudged it I
felt it in my heart you know yeah we
knew it was customizing really senses so
it seems like his sexual abusing started
back in 1994 and what he would do is
that he would pretty much do like his
treatments on these girls where it seems
like from the reports his treatments was
to penetrate them with his finger saying
that it lowered her it helped their
lower back problem hold value now that's
well with his that's interesting angle
easy a [ __ ] Victorian era doctor that
treats hysteria with [ __ ] masturbation
and and and these kids are these these
girls never sure what you mean you and
these children never told their parents
there were reports there were parents
there were people like telling station
USA Gymnastics but then they would cover
this [ __ ] you covered it to the point
where they [ __ ] they actually what's
the word oh my god I'm just so at that -
no no promoted they promoted the his ass
to be like the one to oversee before you
got higher than 9686 let me tell you how
the real world works
okay tell us if you bring money large
amounts of money if you give good
results for anything so the way that
people see these athletes are racehorses
they're just products not human beings
and if you can make these people win
gold medals and all these things they
don't give a [ __ ] if you [ __ ] dead
corpse or like if you kill people on a
Sunday they don't give a damn they know
that
the best and they're gonna keep you
there I think the world doesn't
understand that that's so true yeah
what's the world real life yeah what's
the real life once the world realizes
that that if anyone contributes large
sums of money like like but celebrities
yeah and and producers and whatnot they
they [ __ ] they make so much money for
this company they're protected it's not
right I'm not saying this is good but
you gotta understand that this happens
so you can find these [ __ ] and then
bring them to me yeah yeah yeah there's
actually a lot of sports with this Helen
with even no money they just won first
place really yeah there's a lot there's
a because we personally know people that
where they've competed on a national
level and if you get popped for steroids
on a national level an American team
you're disqualified from the Olympics
and we know someone that told us this
person got popped and beat and they were
still able to compete at the Olympics
and bring home bronze for United States
I had the mic I have a theory it just
looks like you have it no don't do it
please please pan okay no I got a theory
I have a theory that and this is just a
conspiracy theory but I think it's a so
I think that when you when you pull up
like a magazine all these magazine
covers that we have all these
celebrities and [ __ ] like new hot
upcoming celebrities what do they always
do they get panty shots of them bikini
shots of them it's like a [ __ ] Miss
USA thing like they get you in bras and
underwear z' and they put you in all
kinds of different outfits on different
magazine covers and i think it's all a
big like live like for the world's elite
like for the people who really want run
the world i think it's like a [ __ ]
catalog Oh shop that's right and it's
out in the open for all of us to see and
it's like oh I like this one I like this
celebrity I like this new up-and-comer I
like this one and we're seeing in
[ __ ] Hollywood now aren't we like
with all these like speculations like me
to stuff I think it's been like that for
years dude because of the me to movement
that's when
like a lot of these gymnasts came out
with these accusations now there's a
hundred and forty girls claiming that
they had been sexually abused by forty
did he do anything else besides the
[ __ ] fingering but she don't see how
see how this is widespread and known
about and completely covered up for so
long that's right she's signed an NDA so
then now what's happening Michaela
now she's 22 years old she was one of
the fierce five squad that took home
gold four gold medals back inland back
in London in 2012 so that's why she's so
relevant right now so then she was
sharing that her team doctor molested
her when she was 13 we also heard doctor
like their doctor and the trainer oh no
so back in 1993 he did receive a medical
degree so he is the team doctor he was
initially hired as a trainer and he
became the team doctor yeah so then get
and she was saying like the abuse went
on until she left when she was age of 20
so from 13 to 20 she was being abused
and that's just her story because
there's so many of you so many people
know about it nobody cared it's worse
that he became a [ __ ] doctor cuz now
it's like he can just say this is
medically what always told when you're a
kid the only person that's a lot of
touchy there is your parents or doctor
or whatever like you're like yeah I let
them touch my dick all day I don't get
shy Michaela said this quote doctorate
dr. nasir told me I was receiving a
medically necessary treatment that he
had been performing on patients for over
thirty years it seemed whenever and
wherever this man could find it the
chance I was treated it happened in
London before my team and I won the gold
medal and it happened before I won my
silver bull was a treatment finger
begging fingers oh my god [ __ ] hate
this guy and there was an even worse
incident that happened in 2011 during a
trip to Tokyo where she claims that the
doctor gave her a sleeping pill and that
she awoke to finding him performing a
treatment on her in the hotel and she
said that she would she thought she was
gonna die that night oh [ __ ] and so they
do mention that she had already received
a 1.2 a 1.25 million dollar settlement
from USA Gymnastics in December of 2016
and as part of this as part of the
settlement she was also forced to sign
an NDA and that included a one hundred
thousand dollar fine if she ever spoke
about her abuse and when once everyone
found out about this Christy Teegan you
got to shoot the model she offered to
pay for her fine as well as like cool
that's dope
that's when the USA Gymnastics released
this statement they said we have not
sought and will not seek any money from
mckayla maroney for her brave statements
made in describing her victimization
[ __ ] you and abuse about Larry Matt
Nasir nor for any victim impact
statements she wants to make to larry
nasser at his hearing or at any
subsequent hearings related to his
sentencing and then they also follow up
with contrary to reports the concept of
confidentiality was initiated by
Mikayla's attorney not USA Gymnastics
the USA Gymnastics cannot speak on them
on the mediation process which is
confidential and privileged under
California law so they're saying that
they never made her sign the NDA that it
was Mikaela floors you know what they
need to do this is this will solve
everything so if you don't want your
organization to be tarnished and don't
[ __ ] answer like this hang your own
[ __ ] hang your own people before other
people do it yeah I put a picture behind
but then the reliable man they won't do
it they won't do it
it looks up to the lawsuits and [ __ ] so
they never hang their own people and say
these are the people behind this [ __ ] we
are a different group just like how
Germany cleaned up their act
after what happened you don't see them
at which time after World War one and in
World War two
yes II took two times can you imagine
like your daughters like I'ma be an
Olympian and you're like you go honey
and then like this has happened dude
it's so pervasive though their same
that's why so many gymnasts are also
suing the USA Gymnastics who is saying
that it was a requirement to be a see
this guy to see this this guy
but why don't people wake up and
conflate the two things it's like you
see Hollywood's doing this [ __ ] and
they're all covering it up together then
you see the gym team cover doing this
[ __ ] covering it up together then you've
seen the Catholic Church in the past
doing the [ __ ] covering up for anyone
that controls anything nobody sees how
it's all the same page they see it as
it's independent right it's this one
person it's this no any large
institution that has tons of [ __ ]
money and power they're gonna continue
doing this [ __ ] and that's what I'm
saying we're and I see it still two
things that people don't get outraged
about like the have you seen the
sexualization of the star of stranger
things Millie Bobby Brown they're
[ __ ] putting her magazines and saying
like the sexiest stars this year and
she's [ __ ] 12 years old and they have
her like wearin she's hot outfits yeah
dude
she's 13 or something but they have her
like wearing like she was she means like
one of the one of the magazines with
Charlize Theron the cover I saw it with
my own eyes she was like on the sexy
list or something
yeah it's dude it's all out in the open
and nobody gives a [ __ ] to talk about it
like like people may be on a forum
somewhere and go like oh this is wrong
media doesn't run with it nobody talks
about it until until everything blows up
then they all do this like snooze cycle
where it's like oh Jesus this is so
wrong it will can move will cut back
after the weather and and you guys do it
we do it for like their control right
and then and then it's gone so you
better believe the Catholic Church you
think all this shit's gone you think
that's not happening anymore they fixed
it yeah okay total like it's just a
cycle well what what actually happened
with the Catholic Church is when they
get a report they would move him to
another parish right so it's like a
handful of guys but then because they
keep swapping him around he's doing it
all over the US and then all these kids
are getting molested so it's like that's
probably what's happening is instead of
firing or bringing the cops into this
[ __ ] and [ __ ] putting him in prison
there are enablers they're like well
maybe he learned his lesson and he won't
do it anymore
there was a dude's a news article years
ago where the Pentagon got busted like
thousands of computers in the pen
got busted for doing kiddie porn [ __ ]
nobody follows up on it Anderson Cooper
does like a thing where he's like and
won't be sure to look up what's going on
with this [ __ ] never hear about it again
to hold a white from the pages well it's
being a kiddie porn this dude he was uh
he's currently ran out in court
appealing a 60-year sentence that he
received back in December when he was
when they found 37,000 images and videos
of child pornography and on his hard
drives oh my god oh [ __ ] yeah right oh
man I want to [ __ ] penetrate his ass
with a big big Boulder holders yeah
large every day because it's for medical
purposes for his back there he goes back
up yeah
heard he has a bad back and he has to
work for a glory hole yes to work out of
glory yeah yes dude you might like that
[ __ ] though he might like that [ __ ]
don't ya yes sir yeah he has to pleasure
the dick that comes in he might like
that
you know maybe that might be a friend
could be sending on paradise know
whether we could poke little holes in
his dip with a little needle and the
feet on viagra and all that kind of
blushes up oh I like that that is a
really how has it not been done in a
horror movie that's great that's a great
one that's why he's my minister of
punishment he always has the most
creative [ __ ] I know I'm just a
secretary energy how did I get this
shitty job energy of all the suspending
wings in the field I didn't think of it
what I accept the position
[Music]